E aí
e a laranja podre da turma
e não precisava Neve assim desse jeito
acho que já deu para entender logo de
cara mas esse é o meu codinome e essa
essa história é longa é antiga porque
começou na infância bem lá atrás quando
era criança eu era uma criança bem feliz
ainda sou uma criança muito feliz é uma
dor esse muito não mas eu era isso
evitada Aquela criança não tem vergonha
de ser feliz aqui rola na areia e brinca
com qualquer coisa filha única eu
aprendi a brincar qualquer coisa aprendi
a brincar sozinha
e teve um momento que eu percebi que
isso era estranho isso era estranho como
assim estranho uma criança ser feliz
como assim estranho uma criança gostar
de brincar aí ser ela mesma eu sou uma
criança negra sou uma criança gorda e
sempre fui quando eu era pequena eu não
podia meter muito na conversa com os
adultos eu tenho que ficar na minha
brincando na minha coisa minhas coisas e
uma vez eu ouvi de uma parente próxima
que eu era corajosa por ser feliz
é uma criança de 8 anos corajosa por ser
feliz e eu não entendi muito aquilo e
fiquei ouvindo o que ela tava dizendo
assim um comentário entre família
e ele dizia Tamires gordinha sabe as
pessoas olham ela brincando e ela brinca
mesmo ela é desse jeito
Oi e eu já entendi que eu era diferente
você feliz sendo quem eu sou estamos no
corpo que eu tenho
e eu cresci e continue sendo feliz e
tá chegando na escola na pré-escola eu
era a menina do Fundão aquela que anda
com os meninos e brinca com os meninos e
joga bolinha nos meninos totalmente fora
do padrão
é totalmente
é isso não era muito aceito na escola os
professores não dava muito bem com isso
uma menina tem que se comportar como uma
menina como uma mocinha uma moça ingênua
eu não era eu acho editada e de mocinha
nunca tive nada nunca teve nada de
mocinha eu era eu uma vez na professora
falou para mim que eu devia ser muito
infeliz em casa assim gratuito de graça
o geralmente quando a criança é muito
feliz assim é porque ela é a criança que
mais sofre em casa
e era verdade mas não precisava eu acho
que aquilo me marcou deu certo modo eu
entendi ali eu passei entender que
aquilo era uma válvula de escape que o
humor era minha válvula de escape humor
era o meu ar era onde eu respirava de
novo e sempre foi assim todas as vezes
que eu passei por momentos difíceis ou
qualquer outra coisa eu sempre me joguei
no muro e eu levo isso até hoje na minha
vida pessoal no meu trabalho eu sou isso
aqui rir do que não deve rir porque
senão Rio vou soltar eu preciso rir
é uma vez na escola ainda tem uma
reunião de Pais e Mestres a
o e os pais foram chamados com essa
reunião conversar sobre nós e sobre os
alunos em sala de aula e a mãe de uma
amiga foi chamada no particular a minha
amiga mais próxima aquela amiga que fica
juntinho era amiga ela foi chamada e foi
listada Olha a sua filha é excelente era
uma excelente aluna Ela é maravilhosa
inteligente uma amiga branca ela
inteligente ela é linda princesinha mas
ela anda muito com a Tamires e a Tamires
é o caos a Tamires é uma aluna que a
conversa demais é uma aluna que brinca
demais ela ria demais ela fala demais às
comunica demais
é como se fosse um defeito falar como se
fosse um defeito se comunicavam como se
fosse um defeito se ser ser o que você é
e ela terminou falando a Tamires é
laranja pois a turma
e a Tamires ela contamina as laranjas
boas
bom E se eu fosse você afastava Tamires
dela
E isso não aconteceu ela vem me contar
essa história só que a minha mãe também
olha se eu fosse você eu tinha cuidado
com essa Professora porque se tem uma
marcação com a Tamires a gente conhece a
Tamires ela não é nada disso Ela não é
uma menina ruim ela mudou esse era
brincalhona ela faz todo mundo rir Essa
é a motivação dela fazer as pessoas
rirem gente percebe que ela gosta minha
mãe a mamãe que corrigir ia mamãe que
não gostava de ter uma filha calça
quando a gente ia para casa a gente
recebi um agenda aquelas agenda de
escola que eram carimbadas com bom
regular e ruim
a minha mãe não aceitava o ruim
oi para ela ruim não podia ter podia ser
regular não ela sabia que eu não quero
sabia que não ia ser muito mais do que
isso bom era a menina da primeira fila
que fala o que que ele da professora e
vai embora e quando era essa lona ela
sabia disso mas ruim não ruim não podia
ter e naquele ano eu recebi ruim todos
os dias de aula todas as vezes que eu
chegava em casa eu estava com a agenda
ruim e eu era corrigida ela falava não
ele é ruim não uma filha regular Ok mais
uma filha ruim porque você é ruim
Oi e aí passou o tempo minha mãe
descobriu o que tinha acontecido Essa
professora falou que eu era laranja
podre da turma e eu não foi desativada
na professora não minha mãe não era sua
mãe que ela briga com professor por
causa de mim ela queria entendeu
professor ele diga que a razão
o segundo dia que ela foi mais cedo para
para a escola e ficou de longe
observando a gente sair a formação os
alunos um atrás do outro fazendo a
filhinha para sair cantar o hino
Oi e aí ela percebeu que tinha um
tratamento diferente comigo que eu era
menina que ficava para depois que a
professora não dava muita confiança que
eu queria falar ela falava sai daqui
fica ali Cala a boca fica quieta Sabe
aqueles tratamentos de escola arcaica
que tá morto onde o aluno pode se mexer
gente quem quer criar uma criança que
não pode se mexer que não pode falar que
não pode se comunicar
E aí depois ficarem adultos para mim
posicionados que falem que articulem que
vem palestra e
e foi ele que não entendeu o que era
caso de racismo
e ali foi a primeira vez que eu senti o
racismo na pele eu não sabia óbvio que
era racismo e que era sobre isso
é mas depois eu fui entendendo no ano
seguinte eu tive o primeiro contato com
o teatro na escola aquelas pecinhas de
fim de ano onde tem Jesus e uma
manjedoura e Maria e eu sempre fui
inclinada para o Teatro sempre inclinada
para qualquer coisa que fosse artista
Gustavo eu queria eu me movimentava
português matemática ciências local mas
arte eu queria ver as culturais se
fantasiar fazer trabalhos da palestras
não gostava mas
e as duas matérias não
bom E aí teve uma peça de fim de ano
sobre Jesus e eu me prontifiquei a
participar eu quis falei uma Escola
Professora eu quero participar eu quero
ser quem é o principal ela pensa Qual é
a Maria eu falei eu quero ser Maria mãe
de Jesus eu vou brilhar e essa
professora me disse Tamires não não tem
menor coerência de ser Maria a Maria
branquinha você é mais escurinha
Oi e aí eu descobri que o que era
cacimbo o que era a diferenciação de
pele
a criança logo cedo
e ela não deixou eu fazer papel e eu não
fiz ela me colocou para ser um dos três
reis magos
é um dos três
e eu fui eu e mais dois amigos que
também os problemas da sala
Oi e a gente foi brilhante aquela
personagem A Maria foi a menina mais
bonitinha da sala branquinha dos cabelos
cacheados que a mãe fazer contente bem
mas a princesinha
oi e ela travou porque ela travou e
ficou gelada não consegui sair e quem
salvou a peça os três reis magos o
e a gente fez todo mundo rir o gente
magros tomaram a cena todo mundo saiu
falando isso aí de mago Gente a menina
que derrubou o presente no chão virou
acontecimento
o e logo cedo e descobrir que o humor
era a minha salvação
e eu sabia que o artista eu sabia quero
teatro eu sabia que era que era isso era
as câmeras e aquela vai fazer me e
aquela professora me fez ver que eu não
ia conseguir sendo assim nesse corpo com
essa pele não ia conseguir ser a
principal eu não ia conseguir ser a
protagonista e que para ela as minhas
ideias não importavam eu tenho que ficar
quieta Eu Tinha que calar a boca e eu
tinha que ser a codivante porque eu era
Pretinha eu era gordinha e eu não era a
protagonista
é isso eu tô falando na escola lugar que
eu ficava o dia inteiro
o e mora só lá que a Sofia se você aqui
em casa dos outros na rua e também todos
os lugares
é muito cruel com uma criança descobri
tão cedo que vai ser difícil para
caramba
é e continua sendo assim em todos os
lugares na família
Oi e aí percebi que eu não seria aceito
lugar nenhum e ali eu entendi que as
minhas ideias não importavam que eu
tinha que ser engraçada só que eu tinha
que ser fazer os outros rirem apenas e a
primeira bom eu adoro mas que não podia
ter muito conteúdo até hoje eu sofro
isso quando eu comecei na internet eu
sempre fui militante sempre eu sou
aquela que me irrita da mesa do bar que
quando vê já tá falando com você tá
brincando com amigos e quando vídeo tá
gente por favor
e quando eu comecei no Instagram ajustes
falaram também você é maravilhosa você é
muito engraçada mesmo realmente você é
assim você chega fala faz todo mundo rir
máscara toma cuidado com que você vai
falar a internet é muito cruel eles
tavam certo até mesmo a internet é
difícil à beça eles não vão te aceitar
sim
e eles vão gostar do teu amor eu morasse
não tem um ok que afronta Então amor que
fala coisas que não tem que falar
e eu fiquei muito tempo assim não seis
meses fazendo piada sobre coisas
corriqueiras coisas do dia-a-dia
e até o momento que não deu
e até o momento que o menino foi morto
dentro de casa com uma bala perdida e
ali
e eu e não merece E numa dessas
conversando sobre isso me irritando
sobre isso na minha vida pessoal alguém
tentou justificar para mim aquilo que
tem acontecido com ele
Oi e aí não deu eu fiz uma sátira sobre
isso sobre pessoas que justificam a
morte dos nossos Se fosse eu que tivesse
morrido ele não justificar minha morte
ninguém sofrer minha morte eles vão
tentar achar desculpas para ela
Oi e esse foi o vídeo que deu certo
hoje eu vim batendo cabeça muito tempo e
quando chegou nesse momento que eu falei
livremente sobre o que eu penso sobre o
que eu acho fazendo humor com isso
é aonde eles param de rir da gente e a
gente começa a rir deles
é Porque para mim é piada ele fala que
eles tentaram justificar nossa morte
nós estamos trabalhando com essa cara E
aí eu falei basta agora a gente vai
deles é
eu disse papel ridículo que eles fazem
a e foi começou dar certo
bom e quando recebi o convite para tá
aqui mostrar aqui São Paulo eu surtei na
hora falei Como assim tá doido não não
não não não não não tem como a minha
cidade importam São Paulo 10 negras
importam ideias negras importam a gente
aprende a gente cresce entendendo que
não como 10 negras importam de repente
Oi e aí eu comecei a cavar
eu comecei a cavar e vi todas essas
histórias vindo à tona
e eu descobri um abismo de coisas que
eram seu de enterradas cedo mortas tá
tudo aqui
e é muito bonito a proposta é muito
bonito o tema é muito mais do que isso
quando eu respondi o e-mail eu falei sim
claro eu tava lá
eu nem lembro de ter falado isso é como
se estivesse não se estudava aqui outro
aqui falando assim
e não tem como recusar isso né linda
quantas pessoas que iam estar lá
o histórico essa históricos tem que
estar lá você tem que falar fala abre a
boca e fala
e eu falando para mim mas a gente deve
importa não importa tá nem meio vai lá e
fala que tem lá lá lá
as ideias negras importo
E aí
e eu acredito que a educação salva a
educação
e eu acredito que o humor salva a
as ideias negras importo
é a minha ideia é importa o meu humor
negro importa
é obrigado a
E aí
[Aplausos]